so I'm Kaylen and this is Scully you're
probably unsurprised to find that out
I am the Mulder of the family that is
that was very clear from the beginning
so that's us you can find me on Twitter
I know my name is kind of hard to spell
it isn't the pro program though github
and I'm a data scientist I have a
master's in bio stats but I've worked
virgin health companies which in a map
company I worked in EdTech I'm all over
the place but I love data and I love
aliens both things this seemed like the
right place for it so here's what I'm
gonna walk you through I'm gonna talk
about North Star metrics if you're not
familiar with that product thing we're
gonna talk through it talk about metric
design principles cuz I have some ideas
about metrics that I want to share with
you then we're going to talk about how
to create a metric in our it's tidy
metrics specifically we've got some cool
functions and some documentation it's
pretty neat and then we're gonna turn
our metric into a dashboard with shiny
bounce it's very fast it's very quick
it's gonna be a lot of fun so a North
Star metric is is you you know if you
google this you're gonna get like growth
hackers stuff like that it's the metric
that defines is that one metric that
defines how your product delivers value
to its users so I put some examples here
for Airbnb
it's nice book because that's the thing
people are coming to Airbnb for you've
got Facebook they originally used to use
a daily active users metric but now they
found that a better metric was number of
users who add seven friends in the first
10 days and that's because you're north
Sarah metric should it should be
something that helps drive retention and
it should be at the very least some kind
of proxy for profitability for you you
know for your product being a success so
again Northshore metric one metric I'm
gonna breviary does NSM the rest of the
way through this I'm big on abbrevs
here's the problem though
the Northstar metric for example if it
were a number of questions asked
dramatic foreshadowing this can easily
be gained by driving users to your
website so if I just put a bunch of paid
ads out being like I have this website
where you can come ask questions and I
do that forever I'm just gonna drive
traffic in and I'm always gonna have
this perfect Northstar metric and what a
successful product I have except for all
the money on adspend
I've spent you see you see the problem
so sure fine whatever I'm just gonna
gain my Northstar metric no friends I'm
here to tell you that we can do it
better we can account for long-term
retention and we can keep ourselves
honest about those spikes and our
Northstar metric with metric design this
is Marilyn strat her and summarizing
Goodheart slaw you might have heard this
when a metric becomes a target it ceases
to become a good measure so if you think
about it we set a metric and then we say
this is the thing that says the this is
success of our product and then we start
doing things to make our product
successful so we're making the metric
better and better that's why I want to
argue we need safety metrics this is
what I call them some people don't like
this name and some people want me to
call it other things put them calling it
for today and they balance out the
Northstar metric they're gonna they're
gonna guard against you gaming it
artificial inflation's the decisions you
make that influence the metric not
entirely like nothing is perfect but at
least it'll give us a system to really
think harder about what does this
success really mean and while this
really comes from product I hope these
design principles could be carried out
into whatever industry you're working in
and hopefully you can use it and what
you're doing - so I'm gonna use the
example I'm actually also gonna use the
Stack Overflow our questions data
available on Kaggle I'm specifically
gonna use the questions data set I
understand that perhaps the real value
of Stack Overflow is getting your
question answered but I wanted something
that users were actively doing so asking
a question so that's how they're
deriving value from Stack Overflow
they're asking questions getting answers
and gaining knowledge so this number of
questions asks
that's our Northstar metric so let's
break this down mathematically we could
break it down where the number of
questions asked is the average number of
questions asked
times the number of active users where
the average number of questions asked is
the number of questions asked divided by
active users
I can also break number of active users
down that's the number of users times
the percent of users who are active
they've asked a question so if I break
down my full northstar metric I actually
end up with five different metrics that
I can calculate that'll help keep me
honest so number of questions asked is
our goal that's great we do want people
to be asking questions on Stack Overflow
but wouldn't it be great if the average
number of questions asked per active
user was also increasing over time
people are coming back and they're doing
more and they're getting more and more
value out of your product I think so so
these are the metrics we have to
calculate we'll calculate the number of
Stack Overflow our users kind of you'll
see in a second the number of Stack
Overflow our questions then the number
of active Stack Overflow our users
active and like I've kind of alluded to
the definition here they asked at least
one question in the time period the
percent of active users and then the
average number of questions asked by the
active users but now you may be you may
be Scully you may be sighing which I
assure you the Scully in my life does
all the time you're like Kahlan there's
a lot of work how do I do this is it
fast is it easy it is tidy metrics let's
bring this in so this was developed by
Ron dogfighting Athan and Dave Robinson
who unfortunately had to bolt which
sucks because I had a great joke about
how I actually came here just to teach
dear Rob how to do something he wrote
himself and he's gone so you guys got it
without the benefit of him getting it
you can get this on github for right now
and it allows you to create metrics in a
tiny way where we're big on that in the
top by the Rob household so the big
canvas introduces which I really love
which I'm going to walk you through are
these
cross-buy functions specifically cross
by periods and cross by dimensions and
this is going to help you as we're
moving toward dashboards so cross by
periods the stuff in quotes comes
directly from the documentation because
they set it way better than I could it
allows you to take you're gonna need a
variable called date so a lot of times
whatever data you're using you're gonna
have to mutate it turn it into date
you're also going to want to strip the
timestamps off you want it just to be
your month day and it's gonna accept
periods state winterville a date windows
intervals of time and it's gonna create
all of the combination it'll create your
summarized output across all of the
combinations of those I am gonna go
through an example so don't worry if you
feel lost then if you do compare this
with cross by dimensions so this is an
extended group by just like cross by
periods and you take your dimensions you
need some kind of categorical variable
it doesn't necessarily have to be a
factor but you do need some sort of
leveled variable with strings that
situation so if you know if you're
familiar with using the tidy verse
you'll often be like okay I got a data
I'm gonna mutate I'm gonna group by I'm
gonna summarize these cross bys can
replace those group bys they're extended
group bys so let's look at an example
let's say we have the stack overflow our
questions example where we've got the
owner user ID we've got a creation date
and we've got a tag and then we've got
these five things I said we're gonna
calculate to build our Northstar metric
and to turn it into a dashboard the
number of users in theory this is how I
would calculate it of course in this
data because it's actually already
active users it's okay here's the people
who asked our questions this is what the
code would look like I crossed by the
periods I have a variable I realized I
forgot to show you guys the uppercase is
just a list of different periods here I
think I crossed it by day week month and
quarter just to really demonstrate the
power of this I'm only going to cross by
the dimension tag I will admit I took
the questions data and I pulled like six
random tags that appealed to me so I
think in here we've got like deep liar
ggplot2 package data table I just pulled
some time
I was like there's a lot of them let's
do a couple and then I want to summarize
the number of users it would be the
number of distinct owner user IDs but I
know all these people asked the question
we're gonna fake this in a second
bear with me so separately I want to
calculate all my engagement metrics so
this is you know people actually
engaging with stack overflow one thing
that's really helpful is to turn that
questions data I showed you two slides
ago into what I'm going to call by day
questions this is a standard that Dave
taught me a data camp what we often use
by day i've aggregated the data by day
and then questions tell me what it is
it's just a really cool naming
convention that I've carried over into
my own work helps me keep things clear
and straight because naming as we all
know it's hard so this gives us every
question asked per tag per day so you
can see some of the tags I actually
pulled and here's how I would calculate
the engagement metrics I have the by day
questions when I cross by my periods my
tags I'll calculate number of active
users and then my number of questions
asked just get us some ungroup' at the
end of everything sometimes I don't
under any cold sweat at home and be like
I think I didn't ungroup something I'm
sure it's ruining my life somewhere so
just do it just ungroup so that'll turn
it into this this is a metric this is
what a metric looks like we have our
period day the actual date which in this
case is the actual days here's our tags
and you start to see now we have this
all tag that didn't exist before this is
what cross by dimensions does it takes
every combination of those tags and it
calculates individually across so you
can see on 2015 January 1st we had 8
active users 9 question asked we had to
in the data table tag we had to in the
ggplot2 tag so it calculate it creates
that all for you which is going to be
really helpful for dashboarding we'll
see in a second like I said I faked the
number of users so I mean I just
randomly inserted
okay here's the number of people who
could have asked a question about our on
Stack Overflow dear Rob of course told
me if I'd gone to stack overflows
website I could have gotten this data I
should have asked him first that's
another lesson ask for help one thing
that's gonna be critical here active
users any I want to pull the number of
active users on the any tag this is
important for my denominators you'll see
on the next slide so here I have
everything I'm gonna put it all together
we really got to go in here so I'm gonna
take my question engagement bra I'm
gonna pull in my active users any and
calculate my average number of questions
asked that's line three I'm gonna pull
in the fake number these are get my
percent users active and then the code
from the group my period and below just
trims off the current period because on
a dashboard if you leave that in it'll
often show a drop and then you'll think
oh why is this metric dropping it's not
it's an incomplete week it's an
incomplete month it's an incomplete time
period so it's really helpful to do that
and now I have a metric so this is what
it looks like we're excited about this
we've got a metric in the sense like
this is a metric the data format
documentation super important I learned
a lot from fox mulder and we're in the
right place for this so if you document
your metric the nice thing about shiny
bones and shiny metrics is all of that
documentation will turn into the titles
and the tooltips on the dashboard you
can get this has made a lot easier with
this use metrics scaffold function so if
I use use metric scaffold on this
question engagement metric object I made
it gives me this full scaffold full of
to do's telling me hey Kalyan you got a
lot of stuff to do and you take that and
you turn it into this this is going to
be you probably recognize this just from
all of them are markdown fantastic our
markdown talks we've seen this is your
gamal header that's going to go on this
is in particular add our MD a our
markdown metric you can save your metric
you're gonna want to do create metrics
save metrics which type equals local
this was a fun thing I was doing the
default is to pull data from s3 so
you're gonna want to
that type equals Lobo you can also
preview your metric but let's get to the
fun stuff I'm gonna rush through so that
we can get to shiny bouncing
you'll also need shiny metrics but shiny
bones is an opinionated framework for
creating and organizing shiny dashboards
and you get visualizations for free
right now line and bar graphs as long as
you make a metric it's gonna detect okay
I have this metric and I'm gonna turn it
into a line graph or a bar graph
depending on what it is you can also
create your dashboard with a yamo file
and page modules and Ramnath built in
once you've got it installed you can
just pull down in the new project
scaffolded shiny dashboard app using
shiny bones you'll need shiny metrics
installed the preview metrics and a
couple other things are there it's a
dependency so you write your site camel
so here's my actual one for my dashboard
you can see there's all these rules
these are in the documentation my
dashboards gonna be called Stack
Overflow I'm gonna have a sidebar link
called North Star and then I'm gonna
have these tabs questions asked average
questions asked then I create an app dot
R there's some rules here too but it's
going to turn it into a dashboard and
it's not really fun static and the gift
was way too big so I'm gonna show it to
you I'm not gonna live code but I do
actually have this all 100% already
coded for you also hot tip if you're in
an app dot our file and you want to
start an app I am on a Mac sorry Jared
command shift enter I guess it's called
return whatever and I have a dashboard
so let's put some of this stuff we
talked about together so here's our
North Star metric that we created I have
it set by default to be aggregated by
week but I can come down here and change
it to month change it to quarter I can
also right now it's set to all-time but
I could also set it to a custom period
of time I'm gonna go back to month tag
where did tag come in I kept calling
this a dimension the reason we call it a
dimension is because up here now I can
flip over to tag and I can see by tag
how many questions were asked I can
double click and keep only one this is
easy just plotly graphs so the
you normally work with a plotly graph
you work with this I can hover over and
see the exact numbers and now I can tab
through and see my other metrics so I
have average number of questions asked
same thing by tag and if I were curious
okay what does that mean I hit the
tooltip there's the documentation I
wrote so it really brings everything
together if you like walk through this
process end to end you create the metric
you pull shiny bones and shiny metrics
in you have a dashboard a lot of things
for free and you can still write your
own custom shiny page modules and embed
them in here we have some really cool
custom ones that are kind of a mixture
of the shiny bones yellow format and
custom page modules that Ramnath has
built I've done it too I've embedded
like value boxes and stuff on top of the
graphs it's pretty great percent of
users active right now because I think
this data looks like nothing but on a
real product you'd probably have some
sort of seasonality some kind of trend
here and you can stack two graphs on top
of each other if you want I have number
of active users stacked on top of number
of users cuz probably somewhere else at
SEC overflow we know we're number of
users is it's just here for completeness
and then this is what my metric looks
like it's just an RMD file there's my
documentation my setup and then all the
code I showed you is in this so it's
really really cool and I really like it
and I want to talk to you guys about it
all night so please come find me after
so thank you to DCR and Jared Lander for
having me thank you for putting up with
I also want to talk about aliens so if
you're serious about that
come find me or cats dogs it's it's
anyway thanks to Dave and Ramnath for
their work on this and for teaching me
how to use it
and so that I could come to you show you
guys how to use it there's really only a
small group of us who've been doing this
but they are all open sourced right now
and on ron knox github so you could
start adopting this if you want open
issues open pull requests and then come
talk to me later so this is me with the
Robinson family dog
Abbey this is like my requisite final
slide so come find me later you can
email me Twitter me and I'm actually
glad that Danya talked about jobs
because incidentally I'm a couple weeks
away from finishing at my current place
of employment I've got about four years
experience as a data scientist so if
that's something you're looking for let
me know
[Applause]